le 22 mars 2016 quelques jours au fond
après l'attaqué de grand bassam
des bombes explosent à bruxelles et un
ami johan est porté disparu
nous ne savons pas s'il est vivant s'il
est mort nous sommes dévastés
et je me rends compte que ma vie a
basculé
je me sens impuissante
la puissance c'est quelque chose que je
connais
tous les jours je suis confronté à mes
limites physiques émotionnelles et
mentales les mentale sont les plus
difficiles on a beaucoup entendu la
petite voix vous la connaissez aussi la
petite voix qui dit tu n'es pas assez
fort tu n'as pas assez de connaissances
pour qui tu te prends
tu es trop jeune et trop peu
[Musique]
et mon sentiment d'impuissance grandi
depuis longtemps il grandit avec les
attentats il grandit avec les guerres et
grandi avec l'intolérance et il arrive
un point culminant le 22 mars 2016
à 9h11 exactement quand yoann est tué à
deux pas de chez moi
que dire
que faire
comment m'engager sans violence en
restant qui je suis
comment faire sens de tout cela
comment faites-vous sens de tout cela
moi j'écris de la poésie
alors le lendemain il faut que j'écrive
sinon j'ai implose
et je partage ce poème avec les amis de
yoann qui sont touchés et qu'ils me
demandent le publier en ligne en ligne
pour le partager et dès midi le poème
est partagée pour la première fois et
puis les traduit d'abord en italien et
il est partagé et traduits et partager
traduit encore et encore
et aujourd'hui il existe en 69 langues
mais aussi grâce
raymonde evelyne et marceline
il existe aussi en version multilingue
de côte d'ivoire
merci à elle ce poème décidément
traverse les frontières les limites
géographiques
il va toucher le coeur de dizaines de
milliers de personnes
alors ce poème j'ai envie de le partager
avec vous aussi
je choisi l'amour même le coeur lourd
même lame brisée
je choisi l'amour même sous les bombes
je choisi l'amour parce que le monde est
déchiré pas juste mon petit pays
je suis plutôt bien je suis plutôt en
sécurité mais le monde tout entier
chaque jour je choisi l'amour et je
puise dans sa lumière la force de rester
debout pour transformer la violence pour
mettre fin aux guerres
je choisi l'amour pour que nos enfants
soient sauf pour que nos amis soient à
l'abri pour que nos frontières s'ouvrent
je choisi l'amour même le coeur lourd
même l'âme en peine je choisi l'amour
c'est l'amour que je choisis
ce poème me reconnecte avec la toute
puissance de l'amour
il me rappelle aussi que j'ai un talent
une un super pouvoir depuis près de 40
ans la poésie et je comprends que je
peux mettre mon talent au service de
l'humanité et que comme cela je peux
m'engager sans violence et en restant
qui je suis
ce poème jeu l'utilisent comme un mantra
pour m'inspirer les décisions et pour
orienter mes actions par exemple je
croise dans la rue côté de chez moi un
homme il est en train d'essayer de caser
un meuble dans sa voiture c'est un
étranger je veux dire par là que je ne
le connais pas j'ai un peu peur mais
j'ai envie de l'aider
je n'ose pas alors je pense aux poèmes
et je les interpelle et il accepte mon
aide un peu étonné quand même mais super
reconnaissant
et si aujourd'hui j'ose apporter une
aide tout petit tout limité aux
centaines de personnes qui arrivent
d'afrique qui arrive de moyen-orient à
bruxelles épuisée martyrisé traumatisés
c'est grâce à cette phrase qui résonne
en moi je choisi l'amour alors
peut-être que vous aussi vous avez envie
de vous reconnecter avec cette toute
puissance de l'amour avec votre
puissance intérieure et je vous propose
de le faire ensemble
et pour ça de bien mettre vos pieds au
sol de bien vous installer
confortablement
mais si vous voulez vous pouvez fermer
les yeux ou pas ça c'est comme vous
voulez
et puis rappelez vous avec une
inspiration une grande aspiration
rappelez vous cette petite phrase cette
petite voix négatives qui dit tu n'as
pas assez de force
tu n'es pas c'est bon
avec chaque inspiration rentrer dans un
moment d'impuissance rentrer dans une de
vos limites
[Musique]
et observez ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur de vous
est-ce que vous avez des tensions dans
le corps ou
est-ce que vous avez la gorge nouée
peut-être la respiration bloqués quand
vous pensez à vos limites
[Musique]
est-ce que vous avez les mains moites
les jambes de plomb
alors quand vous y êtes vous y êtes
c'est confortable
alors vous pouvez tout doucement parlez
à votre impuissance et lui dire je
choisi l'amour en vous-même tendrement
caresser votre impuissance
je choisis les mots
je choisi l'amour à vos limites
[Musique]
je choisi l'amour à cette petite voix
qui dit de mieux faire
tu n'es pas capable
je choisi l'amour avec de plus en plus
de conviction avec de plus en plus de
tendresse
et peut-être que petit à petit vous
prenez conscience
[Musique]
que vous êtes bien plus grand et bien
plus grande que votre impuissance
vous êtes bien plus grand et bien plus
grande que vos limites
et avec cette phrase je choisi l'amour
vous pouvez continuer à prendre
conscience de votre toute puissance
[Musique]
et faire coexister à la fois votre
puissance et votre impuissance
parce qu'elle a un rôle aussi
tout en sachant que vous êtes bien plus
que juste notre puissance ou juste votre
impuissance
alors vous pouvez remercier vous
remercier vous même
d'avoir parlé à votre impuissance
la remercier qu'elles soient présentes
en lui lisant dans cette formule magique
que vous avez akwaba
et pour continuer cette expérimentation
je vous propose à tous de vous lever
[Musique]
et avec dignité avec respect
en silence tournez vous vers un
partenaire la première personne c'est la
bonne personne
en silence avec dignité avec respect
merci
deux c'est mieux si vous êtes à trois
c'est ok mais deux c'est mieux
et tout d'abord
je vous invite à porter votre attention
sur votre coeur avoue pour l'instant on
ne s'occupe pas encore du partenaire on
sait qui c'est
et mettez votre coeur sur votre main
si vous savez où est votre coeur en tout
cas
et santé le battre
santé le battement de votre coeur
peut-être vite peut être lentement
santé le dans votre main comme il
palpite
et sachez que si votre coeur bat
c'est que vous êtres vivants
c'est toujours une bonne nouvelle ça
et maintenant vous sentez bien votre
coeur battre vous pouvez regarder
l'autre votre partenaire dans les yeux
toujours avec la main sur le coeur
toujours dans le silence
vous allez pouvoir lui parler mais après
et je vous invite à transmettre à
travers votre coeur qui bat à
transmettre à l'autre personne je choisi
l'amour
en silence
transmettez je choisi l'amour par votre
regard
coeur qui bat
et sachez que si votre coeur bat son
coeur bat aussi
et nous avons cela en commun un coeur
qui bat chacun le sien
et continuer de transmettre je choisi
l'amour
avec dignité avec respect
dans le silence
et percevez ce que ça change en vous et
oser ouvrir votre coeur tout petit peu
plus un demi millimètre en disant je
choisi l'amour dans le temps sans
ouvrez votre coeur un tout petit peu
plus
c'est parfois douloureux alors dit
penser je choisi l'amour
et observer ce qui change en vous
et dans votre relation à l'autre quand
vous ouvrez votre coeur et que l'autre
ouvre son coeur aussi parce que pendant
que vous transmettez vous pouvez
recevoir aussi ce message je choisi
l'amour
en sachant que vous avez toujours accès
à cette ressource dans votre coeur ce
battement de coeur il est toujours là
[Musique]
et à présent vous pouvez avec la formule
akwaba de bien arriver remercier votre
partenaire
[Applaudissements]
à noël
que nous portons l'avenir dans notre
coeur
quand nous portons l'amour dans notre
que nous nous connectons notre toute
puissance intérieure
nous pouvons individuellement et
ensemble
[Musique]
contribuer mettre nos talents au service
de l'humanité et ainsi changer le monde
merci
[Applaudissements]